[Music]
weird story recently a state legislature
introduced a bill that would make it
illegal illegal in this country to
photoshop someone's head onto a naked
body without their permission
yeah in other words this means that if
this law catches on it could very soon
be illegal for us to photoshop
celebrities heads on to naked bodies and
it's so much fun so the idea is this
window may be closing fast so I must act
quickly for no reason at all here's Kim
jong-un right now here's Ron Paul Ron
Paul's they're good yeah he was held up
well the Hat is real that's real Simon
Cowell gotta show you Simon Cowell
Nancy Pelosi gotta yeah Nancy Pelosi's
here
she's the only one who's not going to
sue us Winston Churchill you got to get
Winston Churchill on there if you can
explain who he is later I'm Newt
Gingrich Newt Gingrich suppose and
finally John Madden
[Music]
putting getting under the water
[Applause]